[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
just keep on coming today's guest is not
only one of the best Lads that you'll
ever meet he's also one of the best
hookers in the modern era he has an
absolute gun and he's been that way for
Canterbury the Crusaders and the All
Blacks over his 12-year career to date
he's also won NPC titles plenty of Super
Rugby titles and even a Rugby World Cup
and on top of all that he's soon to
become the greatest forward Tri score in
Super Rugby history off the field he's
even started his own drink company
called eclipse and he is just a genuine
Legend on and off the field it is of
course the one and only Cody Taylor
welcome mate
thanks for having me uh yeah a bit
nervous but uh we'll rip into it mate I
am very much looking forward to trying
one of these Eclipse I know you've
worked hard on this product first time
trying it
um but how did you start how did this
how did this all start mate geez oh you
have a taste first and we'll get into it
orange and mango in that one oh my God
it's delicious I know you don't drink
coffee so it might actually have a
coffee replacement so what's in it we've
got creatine caffeine bit of Aladdin yep
Junior Tropics right amino acids yeah
it's sort of sort of uh but everything
um funnily enough this is when it wasn't
our first first idea that's sort of our
Eclipse performance drink but
how we started geez um pretty much
I uh I don't mind devling into a bit of
CrossFit and I've got a good friend of
mine who has a CrossFit gym in
Christchurch and
um
just going in there for pre-seasons uh
doing workouts for you know obviously
rugby
um we used to devil into a few different
drinks uh that he supplied around that
was fed Aid was one of them uh and I
just remember after a workout sitting
there were like mate why the hell can't
we do this like
um these things sell for like seven
bucks a pop in there
we're here drinking them and we could
make a New Zealand product and actually
drink it without having the risk of
being um
having substances in it that's bad for
sport and that was sort of where we came
from and uh
the idea was around more of a recovery
drink at first and
um that's what we worked hard on for
probably a good two years and
um
we got to the point where we had a
really solid drink there and
uh funnily enough with sort of the last
12 to 18 months we've had a bit of a
wall with that one just with the way um
the formulation works and stuff but in
the process of all that we thought well
we could probably make three three
drinks that we would love to do
eventually and this was one of them as
well the performance we sort of got
three pillars that we focused on around
performance recovery and well-being so
the idea was to have three drinks based
off those three things and
um yeah this is more your your sort of
performance something you take pre-game
pre-workout just to get you up get free
podcasts yeah pre-potty during the potty
yeah but um it goes all right and yeah
um it seems to do it do all right we are
we haven't pushed it too hard at the
moment just because the recovery one
um the shed itself politely and uh yeah
but yeah it's it's a whole different
world man yeah this business stuff so
where do you even start you've got your
idea what's the next step like um to
come up with the drink you know you talk
about the formula and that'll sort of
shed itself but like how does that even
look like talk me through it geez so
well yeah it was just an idea and then
we're like right where do we go from
here and uh trust the old Google you
start looking up on the internet and
there's
uh we found out that there's like these
food Innovation companies that are sort
of government funded that um
are paid to I suppose help new
businesses uh become I don't know get on
the Shelf pretty much and become a
a drink or a food or whatever
so we joined up with them sort of signed
a contract around helping us formulate
that and they went all good they they
sort of put us in the in the um
I suppose with the right people and yeah
formulated this drink uh that first one
was a shocker it was great to start with
we had good samples we're like oh yeah
sweet we're on here let's go we're gonna
make a good drinking um I think we made
geez we I think it was something like 3
000 liters was was what we went with and
um on on in terms of scale that's pretty
small but yeah when you're first
starting that's a huge run that's a lot
of cans and labels and boxes to sort of
uh I suppose flush down the drain and um
so how did it not work was it just what
didn't even work at all it was just
terrible it just um
pretty much once you go to
um
like big time formulation and and you go
to a canning line yeah
put from going from mixing teaspoons
pretty much to mixing bags of stuff yeah
there's a big difference and um we found
that out the hard way we thought oh yeah
this will be all right and
yeah the cans just did not uh fill the
way they were supposed to there was
probably some cans with three times the
amount they needed and then some with 10
of what they needed so that was a that
was a big learning for us and then we
sort of went away from from those guys
and along the way
um you meet these people like there's a
brand out there Pacific flavors
um
grins would have used them I'm pretty
sure a lot of New Zealand companies
would know who I'm talking about but
they also help formulate drinks and um
we met a few good buggers in that and
that um company and we still work with
one today
and they they just put us in the right
um
well they they showed us where we were
going wrong and what we needed to do and
ripped it right back and just we just
took a few things out and uh
we managed to get there in the end but
um again we had a few formulation issues
with that recovery one
but they also helped us develop this one
which is probably uh our best strength
today in terms of flavor and what it has
in it so
yeah that's right the business world has
a whole nother world it is when you're
like oh
because this is all all self-funded by
me and my mate and um
yeah when you start literally watching
money go down the drain it's like [__]
here we go
how much more do we want to pump in
um and we haven't actively looked for
people to invest or anything just
because
yeah it takes a lot to get a stable sort
of business running smoothly and and
there's a lot of things we still need to
work on but um hopefully we can get to
that point eventually you got this
delicious drink now on the market you
must be proud of it obviously all that
you've gone through to have now have the
product that you're you're proud of that
you're willing to you know yeah I think
um
what I'm proud of is like we went away
from something that we knew
um stepped into a whole new world and
you're forced to ask questions and and
have um conversations with people that
you'd never even be able to talk to
usually and
um
you definitely oh for me I was
definitely standing like in the deep end
like
some of the even now there's stuff that
just goes over my head with um the way
it all works but uh
you do learn a lot in in a way it's just
like PDM that we do yes what do you say
yeah yeah yeah Circle I love seeing
people dive into different areas like
especially while they're still playing
because like you say you would have
learned so much from this bench even if
it does go
um bad at the end of the day you've
still would have learned so much and I'm
sure you'll get your money back from
your investment at some point but I
think it will be this because man this
is one of the best drugs I've ever
tasted and I'm feeling the caffeine hit
already yeah I don't know how long this
party might go but too long
so where do you buy it where can you get
it from what's the how do you sort of
sell it at the moment we're only in a
few stores we're in a couple gyms
um we're at a supplement store in
Christchurch but mainly just our website
which is pretty much just the name
eclipsesports.com yeah um obviously the
three for the e at the end
was that yours that was a sort of three
pillars angle we went with
um yeah so it's just online and
um yeah we've sort of Give It Away plug
but we've got a wee water lead code if
you want to get oh you're getting
capitals and uh yeah so anyone listening
you want to give it a nudge then there's
a weird deal there if you want to try it
that's New Zealand based only sorry so
yeah yeah so you don't do overseas yet
not shipping like shipping ads app hey
man shipping overseas is expensive oh
man and like a can itself weighs bugger
all and then you put liquid in it yeah
and you know how it is shipping it's all
based off weight so yeah
um yeah we had 3pl Logistics dealing
with it up up north and um that helps
but also
if you're not like continually selling
product then you're just sitting there
and you're paying for that product to
sit there so we're sort of at a point
where we just manage it ourselves and um
chip away and
yeah we'll get it we'll hopefully be
able to like Australia would be the
dream
um but ever since we started which is
probably three years ago now
to where we are today like there's been
so many companies come out with sort of
the same angled drink and it's just like
competitive yeah and you're competing
with some big dogs yeah yeah you are a
big dog and hopefully the worldly
listeners get behind you and support
this delicious drink uh what'll add was
the promo code 15 off wow go get them
like that guys absolutely that's all we
can afford at the moment
just enjoy it and support the absolute
lab but man let's get to your journey I
mean
started you're born in Levin weren't you
so yeah give us a give us a rundown of
your upbringing cheers um yeah so I'm
from
um
was born there I actually grew up in
Australia so um until I was or just
before I was 12 we moved back but when
did you move over there
um I think I was like three months old
or something I actually haven't yes so I
was a little Mozzy running around and
over there I wasn't Hadley Levin really
no not really not really that was more
my teenage years getting amongst it um
but no so I grew up in a place called
crestmead and which is sort of um
the north North Brisbane or South
Brisbane I can't remember yeah
um but yeah small small sort of town
played rugby league most of my time over
there oh yeah and uh yeah awesome
awesome place to grow up I think uh mum
and dad just went over there for work
and there was uh what two of us at the
time and I've got four siblings or three
siblings sorry and um yeah so we we just
enjoyed our time over there and uh come
back to Levin
first week back into Levin played my
first game of rugby
um that was a that was a pretty
interesting
uh thing uh I think the first time I got
tackled I got up to play the ball I
didn't really know what rugby was
um I only think I sort of recall is
watching the All Blacks when I was a kid
in Australia and the old man screaming
at the Telly yeah
um because yeah I mean I followed Lee
card out when I was a young buck and
um I remember coming home for holidays
and like Nana had a calendar with like
this the Super Rugby calendar on the
wall oh yeah I verbally remember being
like who's the hurricanes or like all
these different logos I was like what
the hell is this but um
yeah so my uh I suppose my childhood was
more around Australia and
came back over here
um went to horrified College in Levin uh
where we had our pre-season yeah yeah
this year
um
and uh yeah living's a small place I
think uh I think there's about 20 000
people there
uh sort of in between Wellington and
Palmerston North and not a great rugby I
suppose yeah Rugby's not
as good there as I've seen one or two or
Wellington but
just chipped away managed to make a rip
team sort of under 16's paper team and
that was I think that's where the the
whole dream of rugby sort of grew what
rep team was that was that New Zealand
no no it was just uh we had the under-16
uh hurricanes Regional oh okay
um console all the provinces so we were
playing div two Poverty Bay sure
um
and yeah so I was one of the the two
players to manage to make this paper
team and
uh you know the likes of play Don bird
rigid Goods Mike kying I remember all
those boys
um solomona sakalia like those are sort
of the names Ben Tommy funer I think uh
we're running around back then and
I remember standing in the line just
thinking she's I'm with these young Lads
that have been playing pretty high level
footy yeah um this is what I want to do
and and
um on the back of that there was like a
NZ 17s camp that we had
and that sort of where I suppose the
whole idea of training for a footy
um
came about yeah yeah because I mean your
training ethic you're a very good
trainer like to be fair like one of the
best I've seen um off the field your
work ethics sort of Second To None what
were you like that even when you were
younger and when did you when did that
work if it sort of start
um I was
I think it started like on the back of
sort of those teeth like making the rip
teams um so even at that age yeah like I
was a I was a chubby kid when I was um a
wee fella uh oh yeah yeah I was on a
like you know those big news always a
couple big kids in the team especially
playing League you were one I was one of
those and then obviously everyone catch
us up and I probably went the other way
um and then probably from 15 14 15 I
started going to the gym with the old
man and I think one thing that I I look
back on now and sort of think it put me
in good stead was all of that training I
had to do I had to do by myself
um there was like no sort of unions
pushing me or anything it was just you
go out you go do your running or you go
run by yourself you go to the gym by
yourself
and I think that put me in good stead
and sort of devote some good habits and
yeah that's sort of where it all started
and you're still sort of like that now
like you love that training by yourself
you've got a gym in your house yeah
yeah don't mind the off season and that
sort of stuff eh so those habits have
taken you through your whole career yeah
I yeah like I say I enjoy
doing different things
um and having the time to do it sort of
by myself or
um in my own environment as such and
yeah the gym at home helps and I love
going into six four where with my
business partner um his gym is and you
just surround yourself with different
people it's a different Challenge and I
think it's more the mental side of it
too like
I get so much out of it mentally just
knowing that I just Train by myself and
on the back of that I feel good and yeah
yeah I remember Pablo saying on his FSA
that you're the hardest Gemma that he's
ever met and couldn't believe how much
time you'd spend in the gym compared to
someone like him but
um obviously everyone knows yeah he's a
bit of a freak without the gym stuff he
goes awesome on the field and I remember
yeah like probably the first time I saw
him in the gym he was doing all rehab
stuff and it was I was like geez you got
a rig like that that's all you do you're
doing pretty well
yeah yeah but your point of difference
as a as a player coming through was
always sort of your speed and your skill
set
um was that the same as when you're
young where you're back ordered yeah we
just start off as a Ford you said you're
chubby yeah I was a chubby chubby wee
boy um no I played Lucid problems
College
um were you fast I had a little bit of
toe I suppose I can thank my mum that's
just a bit of a runner back in the day
but um yeah
oh she went and she went all right uh
she met the old boy and stopped so
that's true so yeah Dad's yeah she fell
in love but um no there's a bit of
history there from the uh um from mum
and um and also her sister went to the
com game so running which is pretty cool
um and she probably oh like to say she
would have done pretty well herself but
um
yeah but um now going back to that I was
yeah Lucid prop and then I sort of
ventured into a bit of seven and stuff
when I um went up to Fielding High I
mainly played hooker but seven was like
the second position
seems to be the thing if you don't go
any taller you just end up at Hooker is
like yeah a potential list for it and
um
yeah that's it so what was the reason
behind the move to Fielding oh just just
the rugby stuff I had the opportunity
because 2018 to come down no sorry 2018
Jesus uh 2009 yeah so come down here um
post horoph finishing up the seventh
form I was one of the young ones so I
went back second year seventh pretty
much yeah yeah one of those ones uh and
Braden whitelock
um been uh for the store for fielding
and I said come up here for a year Place
some decent footy some decent first of
Deans and then what was he the coach
he was more of a um facilitator
recruitment there's a few there's a few
recruited recruitments going on I think
this still is
um there's a lot Loxy they're good at
what they do
um and I I knew of like Luke what look
he was the same you as me yeah uh he did
obviously didn't repeat but uh yes I
decided to go out there on board and I
think that put me in good stead for sort
of leaving home uh getting out of living
challenging myself and
yeah we applied some decent fish of
teens which gave me a taste of what that
rugby is like and I thought on the back
of that it helped me sort of come down
here the next year and uh
just enjoy it yeah did you make New
Zealand skills or that year I did yeah
yeah so the year before now I played I
played against Australia for the
hurricane schools sort of like as New
Zealand was named they we they played
like the regions that's right uh yeah we
won that game actually
um this is what you owe 908 yeah geez
it's a while ago is it true you were
goal kicking as well yeah Schoolboy
level now okay
long time ago she's the older doctors
would be no good
um geez this is like Club young Club
things yeah yeah a bit of a gun off the
team
the old road cone cut up but uh yeah no
not these days yeah yeah not these days
but would you back yourself
um 22 right in front of one of those
like penalty shootouts surely oh surely
I'm on the list somewhere
yeah geez and then the move down to
Christchurch
um was that a hard decision for you
obviously you were probably had a few
teams chasing a goal kicking hooker
tapes no
um now I I uh I had the chance to stay
in one or two uh it was Jason O'Halloran
um floating around and sort of
he came around home and had a yarn uh
and also came that year previous I'd
come down to Christchurch to look at the
place
Matt Sexton was running the cutter back
then with the academy and I sort of
decided no
I'll stay and then I'd come down the
following year and oh yeah yeah it was
it was a bit of a no-brainer like the
way I saw it like no offense to mine or
two but um at that time I just thought
if I can come down to Canterbury and
um crack it down here against sort of
what was the best Province at the time
uh then you know I'm rubbing again I'm
rubbing my shoulders was the best and
it's going to make me a better player
and
so that was you know my whole decision
of why I made my decision and then yeah
came down across the road buddy in the
flats
oh
geez who are you living with back then
who was that
um I hear our uh Ash Parker who's uh
General player yeah he's in Japan now uh
big Joel weaverson he was Cannery boy
went to Japan yeah uh and a young fella
Andy Simmons from England his brother
Matt Simmons that played for the Chiefs
yeah and Tasman for a year too I think
that was Andy
yeah Maddie ran around for Canterbury oh
yeah Matt was London Irish yeah yeah he
went over back over home and um
yeah so those yeah all like really like
pretty much my best mates now yeah
a couple years or a year and or two with
with those boys yeah and the rugby
players or some some good stuff yeah
good times and how did you find like
going into the Canterbury setup you
obviously back then you would have had
what Corey flan and stuff still yeah
still around yeah uh now funny was
awesome he's been awesome uh since day
one really sort of took me under his
wing uh
tell me what to do what not to do gave
me a few rack ups when I needed it and
uh also had like Quentin McDonald yeah
um
Ben Finnell was running around then so
me and Benny were like yeah pretty much
the academy boys and button heads for a
while but he's a top bugger and
yeah we're great it's like he's he's
awesome at too so
um I just chipped away it did take a
long time to crack it I think but at the
same time I I think that put me in a
good place sort of to where I'm at now
so yeah it's a hard one for hookers a
because it does take a bit of time to
yeah work on your craft obviously your
line at your set piece yeah um scrubbing
is probably something that people don't
really
understand how hard that is for a hooker
but yeah what do you what was it like
for you did you feel like you were good
enough straight away or what was your
mindset going on yeah I think in your
head you think you're good enough
um
definitely had that why why an eye on
there sort of at the start
um but deep down ahead absolutely no
idea what I was doing I remember my
first year of white as wider Squad with
the Crusaders was 2011.
um yeah got an absolute hide in
pre-season and then like playing those
even just playing those games like
nervous as hell yeah but like oh yeah
here we go and then you get found out
pretty quick that yeah you've got a lot
to learn and
even I've trained like training with
that sort of like caliber Squad I think
back to them boys making the final that
year with the against the Reds like Rito
Richie Brad Thorne because rubbing
shoulders of those boys and I was
[__] myself pretty much every time I
was in yeah but um
yeah it was it was an experience that I
I'm grateful for and yeah yeah I think
from then I sort of thought yeah I've
got a lot of work to do
set piecewise you know that never stops
even today that's so I work on so
um
yeah it was
some tough times but also put me in good
stead it must be intimidating having
that sort of caliber of forwards to
throw the ball into it a lineup I could
imagine like I remember even like when
my brother was at the Crusaders he
always felt like the backs were really
friendly but the Ford's been you know
pretty like old school you had the likes
of thorny and all that yeah
um you know we're a bit harder to
um I guess have a joke around with but I
could imagine you lining up at line out
times
hey I'm gonna see it and the worst thing
is that they wouldn't even catch it
because it wasn't nowhere nowhere near
where it was meant to be
but no oh those those early days were
were very daunting like you know the all
black forwards um yeah the banks like DC
in there daggy even at that time yeah
like towie toe seemed to be handled it
all right but he um
but when I first came to the squad like
as a wider training Squad member I was
sort of seeing that you weren't even
part of the squad so you were chucked in
the dungeon oh that's true different
roads different rooms so they were in
The Sheds um as the normal Squad was in
the sheds and then you were chucked in
another room
um yeah I remember like going in there
it was like me Tom Taylor Sam pratley
um Brendan O'Connor like just players
like that and
just you felt like an absolute deck and
then it's felt like they used to come
and [__] them out they used to come and
use our toilets and coat yeah oh and you
just oh yeah that makes you feel
um but at the same yeah like you look
back and you're like oh fair enough you
know you who are you at that time in
your career and and um yeah make sure it
makes you earn it and want it even more
yeah but times have changed since CNA
like
I guess now I mean you're a lot more
welcoming to these new guys coming
through than what players used to be to
to you yeah yeah well I I think on the
back of that is probably because a lot
of them are playing younger these days
too so like if you
if they're going to be up with you in
the on the battlefield then you know
they want you want them to respect you
and also around the other way and yeah
I also think they'll um a lot more
professional these days the young boys
like the ones that are stepping up like
macca and that they're 19 and they're
getting cracks at Super level yeah
that's when I was playing my first
preseason game and absolutely [__]
myself so yeah but I remember a
pre-season game uh very early on which
when I first sort of noticed you it was
must be hurricanes Crusaders and you
scored a try from about 60 meters you're
one-on-one with the fullback I think I'd
been stabbed and it was I think it was
Andre Taylor when you just stood him up
and ran around and I was like oh thank
God I wasn't still on there yeah I was
like geez he is fast who is that guy
exactly
oh yeah I remember that pretty clearly
that's one of those moments you're like
oh that felt good yeah yeah yeah I
vividly remember Andre being there yeah
yeah because he had a cricket season
yeah I mean he was playing some unreal
footy and he was he was fast I was like
jeez man how fast is this guy I think I
just got him going the wrong way I don't
know what happened there it's all a blue
now it's still stressing about the line
out yeah I probably had him at six in a
row I don't know
yeah but then you eventually obviously
get your crack with the Crusaders
um talk me through your like sort of
starting your debut for the Crusaders
and how that all that week sort of went
um
yeah that was 2013 and I managed to
debut it was against the Kings yeah no
was it I was at home yeah yeah I came
off the bench um
nervous as hell but uh
yeah it all went so fast you know it's
just
it does that you know what it's like and
then uh I think I played five games
between 2013 and 2015 like bugger all
right I think uh
flenny may have got injured once and
that's why I played a few more but it
did take a long time to crack it and I
think it was on the back of
um then just thinking I needed more time
I always think that
uh
you know Todd wacketter and Dave Hewitt
and all that were the coaches at the
time and I think I'm pretty grateful for
the fact that they hung in there with me
because probably those first couple
years they
might have seen something but then had a
lot of question marks and
um
they hung in there with me and yeah I
managed a crack and then 2015 uh
got a lot more game time came off the
bench to the start of the season and
then sort of I suppose worked my way
into starting a couple games and off the
back of that ended up going right off
the back end of the season and
yeah uh still like nervous as hell
because at that time it was still rich
in burrito and all that running around
but
um yeah they'll also like
helped me step up you know they didn't
make me feel like an idiot or anything
car and and yeah those are some tough
years in the Crusaders but uh also
hugely enjoyable because it was when I
first got a crack so yeah were you ever
attempted to change Province or change
change teams obviously or there's sort
of a four-year period where you're
waiting you're feeling like you're ready
you you wanna you wanna play out that
level did you ever feel tempted to leave
or you're always patient there
um trust the sort of coaches like you
say now yeah no I yeah there was at one
point I was real close to changing
provinces
um Hawke's Bay actually offered a gig at
the time and uh
yeah they throw a bit of 10 at me and
yeah as a young father oh [__] this is
gonna be this is nice uh
and it did take
um a bit of thinking and and sort of
like the olds and a few people that you
know trust that sort of said hang in
there and
um
yeah that's another decision I think
really paid off in the end nothing
against Hawkes Bay but
um it just made me sort of
have to knuckle down and and take it
seriously and and off the back of that
yeah and you said you mentioned sort of
how like the first part of your
Crusaders career was quite tough you
hadn't had much success with the
Crusaders for that period which was
pretty unusual
um what sort of changed from that
that run where you sort of had four or
five years without much success to
obviously where you are now we uh you've
won the last six
um
or
I'm gonna be too ruthless but I just
think the detail that we had uh
in terms of the our structure our Strat
all that sort of went up a level I think
when uh like Ray stepped in and got a
different team on board but
because she looked back on those years
and you'd say she's probably had the
greatest paper team that's ever been in
Super Rugby you know with the backline
um
I know Sunny bills there Guildford saw
Maitland all those boys
um you know International pretty much
team and then
yeah we could have managed everybody win
a Super Rugby title and
I suppose off the back of having a team
like that that's why but uh once they
I don't know I think when Ray came in
there's just a level of detail that went
up around the way we play and uh it just
put us in good sense of bloody you know
have a crack and
yeah that's
in that first year was it the first year
I was in where you won it over in joburg
yeah yeah uh yeah 2017. so yeah yeah
that's where the great dancing started
yeah
and talk to me about your All Blacks um
career obviously
um had plenty of caps for them now but
where did it start what was your what
was your day but how'd you find out
um yeah so 2015 that sort of same year
that I started getting a bit more game
time
um
I remember
at the end of your do
always seems to start at the end got the
phone call what do you do absolutely
yeah yeah
um no I just remember Rito uh sort of
giving the year the old shoulder like
um you know just subtly dropping in
little hints here and there and didn't
think much of it uh
and it's just like [__] is that a
possibility oh is he having me on like
he's not one of those guys to like
[Laughter]
um
yeah and then oh the announcement yeah I
was just out with the misses and got
home didn't even watch it and then phone
like
most people phone just goes nuts yeah
I think half an hour later I was over
rugby park doing an interview and made
the All Blacks and
um
Jace Ryan that day
he came straight around home because
he's a Sydney boy from the club
Christchurch Club um so I've known him
for a long time uh he he came around
home as I mate we're going for a beer
and there was a Sydenham charity golf
event on that day so we went out there
and had a beer with some of the club
boys some of our best mates Johnny Mac
Nicole and that yeah
yeah I just remember sitting there like
holy [__]
and then yeah uh I suppose you're going
to the first Camp room and we've given
me a llama you're like this is real
not that he's the like he's not a scary
but I definitely respect him but um
yeah and I debuted in Christchurch so uh
that was pretty cool to be able to say
you know debut at home against Argentina
um
yeah that just a surreal surreal moment
uh doing hakka all that stuff and
yes like that you sort of never never
will forget did you not watch it because
you didn't think you'd make it or you
just yeah it's just yeah I know I didn't
think it was anything like after even
after read okay yeah yeah well it was
only a couple remarks
you know because at the time they were
still real good hookers around yeah oh
like they're yeah like cozy KIVI
um you know Elliott was playing well
that year
and yeah I think those are the three
plus me so I reckon I was just a wee
um a trial sort of name in at the time
yeah like uh so yeah like Nate Harris
had been injured so he's yeah yeah
missed out
um yeah you obviously trialled well
though when you got your chance because
pretty much been in there since and that
was from memory 2015 that so Rugby World
Cup yeah a big year where they don't
often take a punt on young guys but make
your form was that good that couldn't
resist yeah I don't yeah no we're not
right against in my debut didn't do too
much
um I suppose I got meniscus either we
meet pie
um
[Laughter]
um and then my second test was probably
one of my most memorable tests to be
honest because we went straight to South
Africa after the um RG game and uh for
me I followed that was the real trial
because they named Me Off the Bench
again
uh Kip Cozier oh sorry caveat
enough yeah to me that was like oh I
know what they're doing here yeah they
give they're going to troll and see how
I go if I [__] the bed then I'm probably
gone yeah and uh yeah I think I got
about 20 minutes in that game it was a
hell of a missile game
I don't know if you remember cozy scored
a hell of an unreal try
um ran a short ball in and out of a few
people yeah under the sticks that says
yeah when he was like killing killing it
yeah and then yeah it was a real close
game I think we were losing
when we came on we had a had a line out
five out and it was I believe it was
either called coffee or tea bag can't
remember
a woodcock try nothing it's a bit like
that it's sort of similar
um pretty much it was like a six-man
line out that prop turned and faced me
to pretend to get it the Pod went back
and Rico was at half back and he ran and
we just threw it over the top oh and uh
yeah I remember when they caught up like
it's not even like a big throw but it's
like [__] here we go and we scored and
we managed to get in front and I was
like [__] that was the one of the best
feelings I've had as an all-back just
looking back on that and
yeah I feel like those that moment sort
of helped set me up to to get over on
that World Cup and how good is that is
it for a hooker is that sort of the
biggest sort of stressor is it the line
out timeline out throws we uh sort of
pre-game you know when you're thinking
like it's a goal because it's the goal
kicks yeah like as a hooker is it geez I
just hope I can throw 100 line out and
I've probably had a good day yeah oh 100
is a great day
um yeah I've had some I've had my times
and you know still do where it's like
have Shockers but um yeah it is it's
just that thing you like [__] if I like
half a good game is Just nailing your
lineups and whatever else happens that's
an extra bonus yeah it's crazy but then
some augers might be like yeah that's
all good yeah yeah yeah and is it is it
like a mindset thing for you or like do
you know when you're gonna have a good
day at throwing or is it just one of
those things it just depends how it
comes out yeah yeah well I think it's
like gulking I suppose if now is the
first one it's sort of like oh you set
you up you feel good you get rhythm
um yeah you stuff up the first two
you're like oh [__] here we go yeah yeah
yeah
I think everyone goes through that yeah
right that's interesting and then
obviously that year you make the Rugby
World Cup you're off to the UK with
probably one of the best teams on paper
who has been
um we're confident going to that Rugby
World Cup what was what was it like for
you obviously you were young you're
behind Kelsey and KIVI but yeah um
pretty cool team to be a part of yeah it
was it was Unreal like looking back uh
your name third hooker I sort of
had it in my mind that I was over here
just in case
um I only played one game well one test
that whole world cup
um 80 against Namibia that's right how
good got a late try again late dot yeah
yeah
um I think just the experience itself uh
you know with the squad
like that was sort of a time when the
All Blacks were
like everyone was like you're playing
the All Blacks this week yeah
um
and there's just a real sort of the
fellow is a real chip on on their
shoulder to go again
um like all the senior boys
and Jason played some good foot yeah it
was it was pretty pretty awesome to be
part of and watch full-time pad holder
but
um I just remember that like sort of
embracing that role I suppose
um would driven heavily by Liam missing
uh he didn't he didn't play much either
and
I just remember Thursday trainings was
so intense like the boys would get
barred up and then even the warm-up
before a test like you'd hold the pad
and you'd be giving it everything yeah
um and that was what we did and you come
off and like you wanted to be out there
but yes you know you you did your best
to help those boys made us a massive
role though hey it's like an underrated
role in terms of how important it is to
set up a team and yeah yeah obviously
the better quality those guys are the
better sort of prep you're getting and
yeah yeah I think earlier on in my
career probably when I thought I could
play I probably didn't do that in in
this environment Crusaders but uh
yeah you do learn that no that's that's
pretty selfish you're part of the squad
and you want to be successful as a whole
so yeah and were you confident that
they're always going to win that like
watching from the sideline as a as a fan
I guess uh the South Africa test was
probably the one where like this could
go anyway just because of the way they
they were playing as well uh
but the yeah the tone was set pretty
early in that game I remember Rito he
was right up for I think put him in
head-on
um
and then yeah we it was pretty pretty
close that game I can't remember the
exact score but
um
yeah then playing Aussie just felt like
the boys were yeah they were on yeah
yeah and
they came out pretty healthy and what's
the celebrations like after that were
you as a young young guy who obviously
played your part yeah
Oh I thought there was a tournament for
that maybe
I might have made put him no no oh it
was awesome
um yeah we were at Penny Hill Park when
we um our last week there so that's
where England stay for their test weeks
and
yeah yeah there would have been a few
room bills there
that a couple days after the final and
then
not much sleep head when we even from
then to get home because we had to
travel around the cities and it was
Auckland Wellington and all that yeah
yeah that was some good times I mean
fast forwarding four years to the 2019
Rugby World Cup um how did that compare
to you obviously you'd worked your way
into sort of the starting hooker role
um what was the pressure like what was
that sort of Team environment like going
in
um I felt good at it yeah I think we're
in a pretty good place
um
it definitely was different uh I suppose
there's a little bit of
not less Edge like about the squad I
think that was just because in 2015 like
me looking up at the Players yeah sort
of like she's
um
but
a fella were in a good place we had a
couple sort of average games and pool
playing that but
um
yeah I look at like that semi-final week
it was it was a different one I uh
I just remember thinking like well we
just played I played Ireland in the
quarter had a real had an unreal game
boys were like that whole week was huge
like because we'd lost to them the year
was it year before in Chicago
um
so the intensity of that week was was
huge and then we came into the English
week and I just remember
sort of like the language being around
um it's all right you don't have to be
at that level this week to get the job
done and I always sort of look back on
that like
I think we really needed to somehow get
some more Edge out of us because
as we all know that that game was pretty
it's interesting pretty flat from us
yeah yeah and that's the way I see it
like here it was just we we lacked Edge
England you know talking to hindo now in
this environment he's like that was
their Ireland week where they were like
we're right up because we're beating
them the year before and talking them so
yeah it's just funny how much like that
mental age comes into play for tests
yeah massively yeah did you feel it out
there like on the field were you yeah
were you thinking how how can we yeah oh
I just felt like we were just like holy
[__] yeah what are we gonna do
um because we talked about all week we
knew that England would start well they
had the first 20 minutes is their best
20 months they play they just come out
here soon and um yeah they scored like
pretty much straight away and were like
oh we're just gave them everything they
wanted that we've already talked about
so yeah it was tough and yeah again
talking to high news like our D plan was
so simple it was just didn't matter how
many numbers you had out the edge we
were just coming at you and like yeah I
remember vividly is it Underhill the
seven at the time he was just popping
people yeah and um yeah there was just
so much pressure there to yeah we
obviously didn't didn't do very well do
you did you feel that pressure do you
feel the pressure of the sort of nation
going into tournaments like that and
sort of how do you cope with it
yeah yeah you do being from like here in
New Zealand yeah yeah there's a lot of
scrutiny and yeah right there so you
know there's a lot of history there
around being successful and stuff and
um
yeah I you they ride you're riding no
matter what if that makes sense you know
if you're successful then they pump your
tires then if you're not there yeah got
the knife out yeah so there's a lot of
pressure there but
um yeah we love it that's what we do and
you have to expect that how do you keep
it sort of or that level that level
ground not sort of
you know listen to your own hype or
listen to the sort of yeah stabs as well
how do you what's your secret to keeping
so level-headed
um oh that's tough like I think for me
personally last year was a real tough
year
um mentally like I knew there's a lot of
scrutiny there and I had to had to
answer a few questions and I feel like I
got there in the end
um but
yeah you the key is probably social
media is stay off there yeah so
everyone's answer I suppose but um
yeah they say what's your highlights
because it makes you feel good yeah
um which does but uh
but um
yeah in terms of that when it's all not
going too well I think the key is just
not listening to people that
don't know you that well yeah yeah yeah
how hard do you find it because
everyone's you're obviously on social
media how hard do you find it to stay
away from the those articles which you
probably get tagged in and yeah all this
sort of stuff you get comments and yeah
good old DMS they they go good
no I yeah I just don't open them
um I'm pretty bit of a selfless like if
we come off if I've just lost a game
I'll stay on Instagram for a couple days
yeah or at least not open anything that
I know is going to be
um negative yeah yeah and what I'm
thinking back to the is it was it the
Argentina game where you had the head of
throw yeah what was that like to sort of
come back from or sort of go through
yeah yeah
um that was tough real tough um
yeah I just remember thinking oh I was
pretty down in the dumps after that uh
even before that you know I hadn't
played particularly well and then had an
opportunity to play against RG
and then yeah that was that's probably
one of my lowest feelings I've had in it
all back Jersey to be honest is on a
personal level uh and yeah like uh my
family they could tell I was under it
um and then
I just had to regroup I re recoup sorry
and um you know connected with some
people around like Kerry Evans He's A
Mental skills guy he was awesome and
uh yeah it took a lot of sort of soul
searching and looking in the mirror and
um
but uh on the back of that it set up
myself around like I had a lot of drive
to to answer uh you know right the
wrongs and
felt like the India tour I got to a
pretty good place and yeah just yeah
what sort of stuff does he take you
through like I'd be interested to like
you've got their mental skills wizard
I've heard a lot about them yeah I've
never actually spoken to him or anything
but um heard good things what sort of
Staff did he take you through to sort of
get through that all and like you say
you're playing some outstanding footy at
the back end yeah um
it keeps a real simple surprisingly like
he'll he'll ask us a few questions
around like oh just ones that you like
get a bit startled [__] yeah he's got me
here
um but he was surprisingly like good for
me around just keeping it real simple he
was like
you know for example you now you stuff
up the next two throws he gives a [__]
you can still play rugby yeah you can
still get the next task right and um a
lot of visualization stuff
um we've all heard that and
uh he just sort of went through we have
a thing called Hogans we like work out
your personality and um he went through
that with me and
sort of pretty much told me who I am as
a person and I was like just sitting
there like holy [__] he knows me too
well like just things like uh I don't
know I've got high skeptism so someone
tells me something I'll be like it takes
me a while to yeah to believe in it um
and then I've got real low process so
having a process for me is like probably
the worst thing I can do because it gets
me in my head I've just got to have a
couple steps boom and then I'm out of my
head and
um
bringing energy is another one like
voice and energy is when I play my best
footy so that was a couple things you
drove for me and yeah seemed to work
mate how good I'm looking at you now
you're on absolutely
talking too much
yeah
oh it's interesting so I am I'm Keen to
hear a little bit more about like that
when you get through those those patches
like the social media
um when you're in that patch how do you
you've sort of spoken about it but
how you feel like around your teammates
um I know when you've had a bad game
like you just feel so [__] you go back
you've obviously got kids yeah who are
probably quick to help you get out of
that but tuning up to training and all
those sort of things like people judging
you how to how did you feel sort of from
that perspective
uh I think oh you feel pretty small when
you're yeah you're in the the high
performance environment when you haven't
nailed it
um for me tendency probably like most
people is just to go quiet and that's
the worst thing I can do yeah
now like I say I've got a family now so
it's pretty easy to forget about rugby
when you're with them yeah but at the
same time you've always got this little
thought in the back of your head and my
wife knows it because she play rugby
herself but she just she knows when I'm
off I don't know if she paid raggedy
yeah she's a coated yeah yeah
um
not quite just can't we meet you
um but yeah so
no it's alone it can be a lonely Place
yeah
but yeah I have drawn off the energy of
my family and my kids like they they
couldn't give us like a [__] yeah yeah
and the Wee Man Loves code yeah does
yours and
um he's always coming at me when we lose
but uh
but uh they also put things into
perspective like we just we're out there
playing a game and that's the reality of
it but we put so much more emphasis on
that because it's what we do as a job
and you don't want to stuff up yeah man
it's so true way like when you're not
playing well it is so hard to then be
talking all this stuff and like meetings
and stuff or like driving things when
you know deep down you're not playing
well yeah like you say you do instantly
trying you do instantly go quiet but
like you say it's also not the best
thing to do still need to yeah drive
those standards I think the key for that
is like I've learned since all last year
in particular is this you just have to
own it like you have to be like yeah I'm
playing [__] but what am I going to do
about it now and yeah setting yourself
up around a few key goals that you want
to get out of it and just keep working
yeah yeah and it is such small margins
especially for for hooker like a couple
of slightly off throws and yeah you can
feel like you had a bad game yeah yeah
the reality is it's like such small
margins that yeah you know actually a
bad plan now you just missed a couple of
throat yeah yeah yeah definitely yeah
so what's your um what's your plans
going forward obviously yeah you've
signed a long-term deal in New Zealand a
um well three more years or uh yeah
2025. so yeah um
I haven't I haven't put too much thought
into that I have you know overseas does
sound interesting but at the same time
give them the age of my kids like I've
personally some people are different
find it hard to think that they'd go to
like a foreign or a different school
yeah like in Japan or whatever and
um yeah France would be pretty cool
experience a lot of rugby played but uh
yeah I'm pretty open like
my body feels good I feel like I'm still
playing at a level that's
um you know High and
if I get to the end of 2025 and I'll
probably re-evaluate but
yeah there's nothing stopping me from
wanting to hang around and you haven't
got a sabbatical or anything you're here
till 2025 is it no I do have a
sabbatical post this world post 2023 so
yeah
um yeah open to Opportunities there uh
but if yeah if nothing sort of Happily
just roll out in super and get stuck in
again
um or there is option of just having six
months off and oh yeah yeah yeah so
we'll see what happens what would you do
on that six months just throw a collapse
into it so there's no driving this is
nuts
no I don't know yeah I'd probably just
have a six-month pre-season saying
stupid like that
yeah like I say I enjoyed I enjoyed the
training side of things yeah so I just
totally dabble in saying different
crossfit I don't know oh yeah yeah
interesting so you'll make that decision
post World cap on what you're gonna do
um or I'd like to say have a have an
idea of what I want to be doing in the
next like few months but you know
opportunities are few and far these days
for hookers especially like if you want
to go to Japan
um flooded Market flooded Market yeah
and uh they don't wanna
hooker they probably want some wrestling
back so yeah yeah you could be here
geez no yeah oh true that's interesting
that even like an all black Legend is
still struggling to get a gig in Japan
yeah well you know you've been over
there
um
I think it's a common thing for even
like not just all backs like most
International Players now
I think when I last heard there was only
a couple more spots left before
next season rolls around so
yeah at the same time like no lie the
money has to be good to want to leave
yeah it's moved the whole family we've
got a pretty good lifestyle over here
yeah what rugby Parks 12 minutes from
home
um and what a home it is yeah yeah yeah
really lucky there the golf course and
stuff yeah yeah
interesting decisions but you you said
you played
um League at the start of your sort of
care have you ever had any Twitches or
urges to go to League I know you're a
pig yeah Warriors man
especially now yeah yeah yeah
no I'm I'd love to have a crack at
league but yeah
32 yeah a little bit low yeah Kevin
campus
yeah yeah that'd be pretty awesome
though Britt komoly was my favorite oh
was he growing up yeah Melbourne storm
yeah even though I used to go watch the
Broncos yeah yeah yeah I think Molly in
the house yeah
he's actually didn't even say hello to
me when I wanted to autograph I still
remember that oh that's right how old
were you oh geez that would have been
like nine or ten my
coach's mother had something to do with
um the Queensland in the Broncos so we
managed to get down to a new South
training yeah
um
yeah got snubbed at the bus
but it's crazy that that one little
moment you've remembered for like the
rest of you yeah yeah that's why I like
even like you're sort of in a swimming
position now like you'd like to say
you'd never do that yeah oh you get it
at the same time like you're in the
other side of it you're like sometimes
you just want to get out of there yeah
yeah but oh one thing you've always done
you always you're always good with your
time with kids I know that's right
you've had a big effect on my boy Toby
who was the next Jordy Barrett number
one fan now he's quickly changed to
Luca's dead Cody Taylor I look for all
that I think play that this is the
soccer in the air
yeah good stuff so NRL um sabbatical
potentially if the right team comes
calling yeah yeah we'll see
um Avery player says that though that
love to sort of give it a go see without
fits but it's just the logistics of it
are quite hard eh to sort of make it
happen yeah I'm Ash was one of my best
mates he's been over there for about 10
12 years now and yeah he's because he's
been immersed and it's nothing for him
but uh
you know I've been to his house and I
look and I'm like he has two kids in
this thing and yeah so how did they do
it yeah yeah no like no yeah I know you
make do and um
you do yeah you do but uh yeah you gotta
convince your other half too yeah that's
the real sound yeah yeah because if
they're not happy she's you know it does
affect the footy yeah yeah yeah and life
for sure and what about post footy
obviously you've dabbled into business
yeah you're on your way there is that
sort of where you see yourself
to be honest I don't really have a clue
like I'd love to say that this is going
well with the eclipse stuff and
um I've always said that I'd get on the
tools my brother's a builder and I do
really enjoy the property side of things
yeah
um My ultimate would be to have one
whole year off and just renovate a house
or something that would be if I could
have the way I want it that would
probably be what I do for the first year
and then who knows become a flipper I
don't know yeah so you're pretty handy
with on the toes you could you could do
up a house by by yourself get on a brush
baby yeah like a few nails but no I I
think I just enjoy
um trying to do new things and yeah
um you know build a deck or something
yeah I could do that yeah yeah that's
the house might not be Plumb but it's
buying all these houses
yeah
we'll see yeah Bears does that excite
you though or post footy you've
obviously got a few more years left but
like post footy how do you feel about it
obviously speaking to Tommy Bateman
recently and all the message messages
I've had around that is how nervous guys
are about and how much they sort of
struggle through it but yeah I think
you're you're going to be all right just
how you're going
yeah like I you know Timmy Bateman's a
prime example of someone that did it
while he was playing and yeah and set
himself up not through lack of hardship
or anything he's had his times but um
no I I think I
to be honest yeah if I had to walk away
from the game I'd be pretty content
around
um what I've got away from footy um
huge like family man I wouldn't mind
even being a house husband for a bit and
loose go back to working too
she came back to go back to the wing she
hates her eyeball mate it was that was a
good thing
yeah oh god
um
but now yeah my kids will be my driver I
think from now on and as long as I can
I don't know dabble in a bit of exercise
and and um
yeah watch him grow up I'll be pretty
happy yeah mate I could see owning like
a gym or some sort of Wellness Center or
something hey I would love that yeah
don't don't want to cut oh Studios
yeah Matt you're the perfect extension
for us but right as always we have gone
to our Instagram for some questions I've
run them down
um you had women thousands come through
you're such a such a celebrity
um but I've had heaps of I've cut it
down to a few good ones but first
question this guy sort of came up on a
few of them but how do you wind up dying
curls
there's a few around what's it like
playing them and that all that sort of
stuff but Kelsey's obviously a woodland
favorite yeah he's a top bloke he's a
great man off the field
at times I've questioned that on the
field not against me though because he's
he's a he is a good burger to me yeah
you guys I've never really seen you guys
going out today no I think we've had
like one tiny little thing was at home
against them a few years ago
um
I can't even remember what that was
about a scooter might have been involved
in there actually um but uh
geez if you want to wind him up just
[__] name in a rock or something it
does not take much you could tickle him
yeah
well how come how come he disorder
doesn't go after you ever you guys got a
relationship from the All Blacks or you
made a truce early on no just two Noah
boys
yeah he came to my little 18th shindig
identity oh so you guys go way back yeah
we go way back um I was playing sevens
for horror for Noah um and has all like
three of his best mates were in the team
oh like man yeah was there and stubs and
that and uh yeah so that's where I met
cozy put on a personal level and he
ended up coming to like
18th uh birthday party yeah
um all right that would have been a day
in Loveland at home in the garage then
we went to Molotov
so are you a claw brother no no she's no
no he's he's um he's the south of the
vanilla so yeah not that tight
oh that's good stuff okay next one
um if you could play any other position
what would it be and why
I would love to play 12. yeah yeah be
quite quite cool though just I don't
know that sort of On The Fringe of uh
the playmaker they get the ball in the
hands a bit more and yeah yeah you like
a nanny little mate type
Jeezy that little unit no I don't know I
just feel like that'd be a good position
yeah yeah good to get that out there for
any Japan clubs meeting at 12. yeah
who might need another one too
yeah okay do you ever get mad at the
locks if they drop the ball at line out
of time
oh yeah yeah not often it's their fault
but
um if it's closer now yeah yeah
geez it's probably the
I actually got mad at Richie McCall once
he um dropped the line out to the back
dead cold and I was because I was so
nervous throwing to him and it was a
perfect seed in there dropped it cold it
was the first time I was like
did you spray him no I didn't spray him
but just you know that look I would
never swear okay they're clear geez
there's no way of being the right to do
that
but um yeah yeah just gave away just
like evil yeah and then I said sorry
oh that's classic okay would you ever
play a game for horror if you know Capri
oh I was yeah funny and I was so close
last year to having a crack fight right
yeah yeah I think just the way that um
sort of games panned out it almost
worked out for both me and cozy to have
a run
um
and I actually I don't know oh that's
all right I um I've got it in my Cannery
contractor if it works in terms of
availability if they've got good enough
Squad members I can go play for the Noah
yeah yeah I got that in a couple years
ago and yeah just waiting for the
opportunity to do it all right how good
would that be yeah yeah sell out Levin
for sure back to the domain so you and
Kelsey were gonna do it together well I
think he's got the same thing oh yeah
um and yeah last year it almost worked
out uh but we've always joked oh we have
to both go back and yeah one can play
hooker one can play or 12. or 12 10 12
combo I'll kick the goals
so that's mainly got to work out around
the all black schedule then or they have
to release you uh fuzz was fine with it
um yeah it was it's more around the
Canterbury uh yeah the the time frames
of games and then Canterbury having you
know sufficient hookers or whatever and
there's some couple Young Guns so well
surely Canterbury aren't sort of relying
on you for their squad no those are
never available anyway yeah all blacks
so yeah yeah so there's a likelihood of
that um but I would have to yeah pan out
well there you go for a funeral fans I'm
gonna get
experience something absolutely special
okay next one can you ask him why he got
horror funeral Copley banned from the
yna hotel in Poverty Bay who's that yeah
the one that we pay oh is it Boya
nay Chase oh the hotel and Poverty Bay
how are we going Vic that wasn't not me
that wasn't that no we had under 18's
tournament up in Poverty Bay and
um
you know what
Heartland
Jesus we're in like some motel and oh we
had a court session and
I think by the end of the people were
running around nude on the beach
um and then the ruins were an absolute
pet and yeah there was a massive bill at
the end and sure but it wasn't me
is that from like Ethan Pollock or
something oh I haven't gone probably big
Polly it wasn't him yeah maybe Sam Hayes
even oh yeah few of the labs anyway okay
best story slash memory playing for the
bus drivers oh
what a team uh
oh I wouldn't the best times was lip
sync we had a lip sync as Club rooms uh
thing we teams going and they obviously
Lip Sync songs and it's a competition
those nights always fun at uh at the
buses down at the keshi club but
uh what do you do what's yours oh if you
go You Gotta Dance I did it for Colts
one year yeah
it was not the main character but um
that's a good night but no I think
semi-final we played Brighton was
probably one of my most most memorable
memorable games we had a pretty good
team with Tyler but I know running the
cutter was in 2014 and um yeah boys put
on a show and made the final and then
Bluey didn't play the finals but
um I'll hold that against them where you
go kicking me
oh well that was the year they made the
final we made the final with the Taz and
that was as last year before he went to
Ireland so yeah I understand
right we needed to steal the ship oh
good times with the bus drivers okay
next one who do you think the best
hooker in World rugby is at the moment
and why oh at the moment it is tough uh
I think those six nations boys I
wouldn't have one in particular that
much and he's playing pretty good footy
then Sheehan he's going Ireland
he does not look like a hooker yeah six
three or something and
um but no I think you
from the previous games I'd say Dan's
playing pretty good for Ireland yeah
he's really young too is he how old is
he oh is that 23 20. he's four years
later okay next one sports aren't
thoughts on Sky row becoming the ab's
head coach I've never heard the nickname
uh oh he'll he'll he'll have his own
flavor to it I think uh he's um
he's good at what he does he's great at
managing people I think I've said this
before and like media and stuff but I
think that's his gift is ability to
connect with both the higher sort of
suits of the franchise or of the union
and also the the coaching group and
players uh drives mindset and theme
really well and
just adds his little bit here and there
here's a character yeah good for you
good for you him getting the role do you
think right he's obviously a big fan of
yours you got oh three more years I'd
love to love to be able to play under
him um you know to get an opportunity to
play with them at that level would be
pretty cool be interesting to see you
know like from being with them in this
environment to that environment what
what challenges he would have
um because it is different but um
yeah I don't know we'll see be nice mate
looking forward to it okay what advice
do you have for a hooker who wants to
play professionally
oh
just never stop working throwing those
seeds um
yeah I think that's what I measured on
as as a hooker uh
because you said it before but I feel
like I'm yeah I agree around like an
undervalued position I feel because it's
such a key role to helping a team be
successful you know it's a pretty
specific skill to have and it never it's
never perfect and I think you know I
just thinking like Steph Curry is still
working on a shot to this day and he's
unbelievable so yeah you can never stop
right like that and about the value I
think that's good for Japan classes
it is an undervalued position though hey
if you can't win your line out yeah
they're gonna have a long day at the
office yeah yeah so get hookers paid
more
okay is there anyone you've been
genuinely scared to tackle
scared to tackle jeez
nah not no that's good scared's the
wrong word isn't it it's sort of like oh
[__] here he comes yeah
I think I had to take a Will Skelton on
a short ball and that was pretty he is
massively massive yeah but probably
today's day jeez
boys getting bigger a Big Tomato
Williams will be pretty tough to take on
a shoe but
some Big Boys around do you find it are
they the hardest guys for you like the
is it the big guys well it's nuts those
like nuggety like Nani for example you
know those boys are tough to take
because they're just in the the GM
Brothers yeah yeah they're surprised
they're just so like hard yeah musty
hard boned and it's like just little
little Hoops of Doom eh
boom see ya you would have had to head
90 off the back of the because you're
off the back of the line at you yeah I'm
coming at you oh a couple times we've
had a good couple running actually yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's always always love
off the field day but I feel it's always
yeah
oh good work okay next one
um which team are you least which team
would you least like to face in the
Rugby World Cup final
oh at least uh
oh that's probably
France would be just given it's in
France like they're yeah they're playing
great footage too I think are they
second in the world rankings so
yeah home crowd that's uh yeah
I think that would be probably the one
of the greatest experiences you'll have
uh if that was the case because of being
at home and yeah just playing there in
the past even for just like test matches
the crowd is pretty nuts yeah they all
get their Flags out and stuff yeah yeah
so
um that would yeah that would be a huge
challenge working how you feeling going
into that Rugby World Cup
oh it's I feel like it's
so like there's no clear
um country that's sort of favorites so
open isn't it yeah it is like oh you
know on your day anyone can beat anyone
um
definitely feel like we're not at a
level that you know we've been in
previous World Cups in terms of
the
um
thought around us or the perception
um so it'd be interesting French France
round one yeah so yeah
let's go yeah but you're confident in
the squad and in the in your ability as
a team to still get the job done even
though like you say the I guess it's the
aura around the All Blacks at the moment
isn't like where it's been previously
heading into it but you're still quietly
confident you'll be able to get the job
done I think so I think off the back of
last year's work that we did um
like we got to a place where we were
playing some good footy and it was a
game the great thing about it was like
pretty simple stuff that was changed and
although we didn't win that last test
like we put ourselves in a hell of a
spot to have a dominant performance and
then yeah we draw it but
um there's some good things off the back
of there I think we sort out
a couple more things and we'll be right
you know I always say defense wins
championships and I think we can get
that stuff right we'll be in a good
place exciting times for all black fans
I'll be loving that
okay next one this one was just a
statement loves an eight percent I've
heard this pop up a few times but
obviously you do love a good eight
percent
is that an eight percent diesel what is
it
I cannot drink Bourbon and cokes that
would be the last thing I touched is
that what it is eight percent payments
I'm assuming
um yeah no I'm space Summit man yeah
okay next one throughout your career who
has
who has gone the best on the diesel
you would have had a fair few days 12
years I've had a few all the way from I
guess
no they're the worst
um
geez one of the most impressive people
that can just keep sort of going and
fall asleep and wake up and keep going
it's metal oh
yeah he's um
funny he turns into like a little T-Rex
and his arms
who just fall asleep on the couch and
he'll still be holding the handle and
you're like sorry
wake up and never sleeping yeah he's
always there somewhere
awake or a slave Tony just you don't
know because his eyes are like just the
same the whole time
yeah oh man I wouldn't have picked that
Tony is one of the greats but yeah he's
someone need to get on actually he is a
legend yeah he's a top boat okay next
one what's the biggest prank you've
pulled on a teammate I didn't know
you're a big prankster yeah I'm sorry
I've got nothing here
I'm far from one of the funny ones or
the pranksters
I was like looking forward to that one
okay next one favorite try now this will
be probably your hardest one you've
scored about a thousand
uh
jeez how far oh one of them would have
to be that lines try other try and get
scored against the Lions in the first
test um
just on the edge here only had to run
talk me through it
uh oh that's probably more around the
hype of what the lion series is like um
unfortunately cozy was injured so got a
great opportunity there to play and Ozzy
again like real nervous and
we've called for the tap and go it
wasn't even really on and uh nuggies
just slung It Wide dagger swung it to me
and
throw it at my toes I've had to pick it
up somehow and then just start in the
corner and
I was pretty hyped about that I think
you can see it in the in the highlighter
I think I throw the ball up and give a
big chahu yeah but that was just me on
the back of the week and the occasion
and yeah the opportunity I was pretty
pumped up mate what a try I love that
okay how much does breathing
how much do you do how much breath work
do you do throughout your season
uh
yeah that's a song I've only done for
probably the last couple years with
Nigel Beach
um you know if you heard about him he
works with Wim Hof yeah was it uh and
there's a guy Patrick McCown from
Ireland who's got some good stuff around
performance breathing uh I do a few
sessions a week like oh
anyway from two to four
um
but it's it's all just uh based on like
breath holds and and stuff ones for
Recovery once breath holds for
performance and stuff and I was doing a
lot last was it last year
um some running breathing work which is
quite interesting yeah
yeah it won't get into detail of it but
uh I find it does help like in terms of
being able to keep going without with
less oxygen and
um especially that recovery breathing
like the wormhof stuff is
some people think I'm stupid but uh
you're ahead of the game right yeah
there's something there we actually had
to do it for the World Cup in 2019 and
on Fridays before the game oh there's a
lot of um
Kickback from there day yeah um what
should I get like it's not for everyone
but uh I find it pretty yeah any chance
to get an AJ yeah yeah just something
different because you also you saw in a
regular yeah into your colds yeah you do
you do pretty much everything
help me
um yeah I love I love a song I'm in
sauna most nights and then uh cold
immersion is something that yeah it's
tough but yeah the old cold shower and
stuff is yeah a must these days but look
at that yeah yeah in the best shape of
your life yeah your body's feeling good
hey you've got no real niggles don't
really remember you getting injured too
often yeah yeah you look after yourself
well I'm pretty lucky I think yeah off
the back of the the work you do helps
but I have been pretty lucky I've only
had I had a serious injury in 2013 with
my pick but other than that
the odd calf here and there and just a
constant sore neck that's just scummy
yeah yeah the darker Huts yeah how hard
is that in the scrum like as a hooker
that front row pressure like
um oh it's it's the third hardest
because you've got the elucid in your
tight head but it's still
been in the middle there with you both
arms around yeah and you're pretty
vulnerable but um
I'd say it has gotten harder and harder
it seems to be everyone's getting
stronger and true everyone's doing neck
work these days and stuff so yeah
I'm hanging all night and you what feel
that where do you feel that pressure the
most in like a scrum like
oh are you feeling it when you're like
Jesus is we're on here
oh yeah it's all like around your
shoulders and stuff like if you don't
have your shoulders on and someone's
coming at you your neck is all crammed
up oh yeah no good yeah yeah so yeah
yeah it's not nice
it sounds horrible yeah you come out the
sunroof every now and again yeah
okay two more why are your warm-ups
twice as intense as the rest of the team
that's it from Marcus that might be Mark
Stephanie it is
he's made us oh good on you Mark
um
oh I don't know I just I feel like if I
get a good blow on I um I get the old
ticket wind early yeah
yeah that's actually not that hard he
always gives me [__] about it I've never
noticed that like do you go no I just do
like I do quite a few lengths and I do
that some of that breath hold stuff oh I
am
yeah so it's not too hot I think he's
just giving me [__] about liver since I
sort of fist come about yeah good man
like we have uh Champion okay last one
best piece of advice you have for a
water lad listener ah
I know you've got good advice for me
I'll probably just
um
don't be afraid to be different I think
uh you know give me everything a crack
it's something that I've always tried to
do
um and not everyone's going to agree
with it but if it feels right then it
works for you I think yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
and on the absolute money oh there's the
Instagram club for sure mate you are on
absolute Fire and Water what a pleasure
it's been to have you on the podcast
awesome to catch up you're you're a true
legend of New Zealand Rugby Crusaders
Rugby Canterbury rugby horror
right it's been awesome to have you on
and go through your journey and even
share an eclipse with your water drink
yeah 15 off what are their discounts 15
what a land but I appreciate you um
giving up your time and coming on the
podcast mate no all good bro all good
all right thank you for having me you're
a legend
[Music]
[Applause]